as she held her firstborn baby kate
rhiannon davis and her husband richard
had no idea
they were about to suffer the most
unbearable loss
fabulous feelings of you're now a dad a
first-time dad
some six hours earlier to the lowest
part in your life
of cradling your daughter as she died in
your arms
baby pippa this is pippa griffith
soon after she was born she had an
undiagnosed infection
and died the next day i should have
started school this year
and he thought about a small anniversary
of christmas or
birthdays it's
when the kids are playing out like in
the park here you know there's
some there's something missing
adam cheshire will never live
independently
after mistakes when he was a newborn
left him permanently disabled
my son has these disabilities because
people didn't do their jobs properly
for that i don't think i'm ever going to
stop being angry
and i'm certainly never going to stop
grieving the child that
he could have been perhaps even should
have been
these are three of 1862 families
the victims of serious failings in
maternity care
at the shrewsbury and telford nhs trust
over the last two decades there have
been cases where women were blamed for
their loss
and missed opportunities to learn in
order to prevent serious harm to mothers
and babies
there was a culture to keep cesarean
section rates low
even though in some cases a caesarean
delivery would have avoided
death and injury and there was a lack of
kindness
and compassion from the maternity team
trusts have got to start working
together
in partnership regionally
to ensure that there is rapid learning
from serious incidents
that they've got a water tight system
for assessing if harm or potential harm
has happened
after years of not being listened to the
victims have finally had their voices
heard
we would have kate with us today aged 11
and a half
had people done their job it's very hard
to come to terms with that that we
should have kate here today with us
i took strength
from my daughter
and have continued to battle
in her name to ensure change and that's
given me
strength to cope from the trust
and apology we cannot change the past
but i want to reassure women in families
that we will
continue to make positive changes the
report lists
27 things this trust needs to do in
order to improve its maternity care
and it goes further saying maternity
services right across
england need to take immediate action to
ensure the safety
of both mothers and babies the scale of
this
tragedy is so large the police are
investigating
for so many families the suffering will
never
end becky johnson sky news shrewsbury